you know most of the time when we hear
about taxes we hear about democrats
raise taxes republicans lower taxes but
when you
study the history of taxes in the u.s
there's going to be many things today
we're going to say you got to be kidding
me pat
who came up with the irs you're going to
be blown away by who came out with the
irs
the whole idea of holding your taxes
when you get paid in your payroll
who came up with that idea which
president raised the national debt the
most
which president raised a percentage on
dollar amount then we're going to talk
about the correlation between war and
taxes and why does the u.s have so many
military bases around the world
compared to russia china france all of
that stuff we're covering in today's
episode
[Music]
all right so stick around to the very
end because i want to have my final
thoughts on the pdf for you but let's
get right into it 1754 to 1763.
during that time the french indian war
took place which the brit started taxing
the colonists and the colonel said wait
a minute
why are you raising taxes without asking
us how come we don't have any kind of
representation
that led to taxation without
representation american revolution began
and the founders wanted lower taxes and
representation which led to 1775
to 1783 the american revolutionary war
by the time it was done obviously u.s
became a country and u.s had two forms
of taxes tariffs
and excise taxes so that led to the
tariff act of 1789 which was a 50 cent
tax
on foreign ships per ton and it was six
cent tax
on american-owned vessels per ton okay
so that's 17.89 then we go to 1792 to
1802 which was the french revolutionary
war and this
introduced us to property taxes and then
in 1812
to 1815 it was the war of 1812
u.s declared war against the brits
because the negotiation was going
nowhere so madison wasn't happy about it
and by the way the whole story about
star spangled banner
comes from the war of 1812. so now it's
when the juicy stuff begins so in 1861
to 1865
civil war breaks out in america right it
wasn't pretty was ugly
very expensive that's when in 1862
a president known as one the greatest
president of all time if not the
greatest president of all time lincoln
came up with the revenue act of 1862
which lasted for 10
years and in 1862 was the first ever
progressive tax
three percent on income earners between
600 to 10
000 a year five percent on those making
ten thousand dollars or more
only about ten percent of americans pay
taxes abraham lincoln known as one of
the greatest presidents of all time i
have him in one of my paintings in my
office
on july 1st 1862. you know what he
started you know what he introduced to
us
an organization you may have heard of
before called the irs
yes the irs was started under lincoln
in 1862 with the idea of having the tax
withholding system which means you make
a thousand dollars in a month they
wanted the employer to withhold the
taxes
to pay to the government why because
lincoln said folks were just at the
civil war
very costly very expensive we got to pay
this off we need you to agree to pay
some federal income taxes but when we
pay it off
we're going to get away with this so
guess what happened started in 1862
do you think the federal income tax ever
went away it did
10 years later 1872 they said we paid
off the war guess what
no more taxes they went away with taxes
and went back to what it used to be
before
in 1894 pollock versus farmers loan and
trust company
1895 congress tried to impose a two
percent tax on earnings in excess of
four thousand dollars
in 1894 tax was challenged in court by a
massachusetts resident named
charles pollock the supreme court ruled
in his favor
striking down the tax because you cannot
go out there and tax anybody for no
reason
but the socialist union party the
populist party and the democratic party
sat there and said we got to figure
something out to be able to tax people
what is this all about so in 1913 we
came out with the 16th amendment
and here's how it reads the congress
shall have power to lay and collect
taxes on incomes from whatever source
derived
without appointment among the several
states and without regard
to any census or enumeration
so that's how the first permanent income
was levied in 1913 influenced by the
socialist labor party
the populist party and the democratic
party it was one percent for those
earning between zero to twenty thousand
dollars
two percent for those twenty to fifty
three percent for fifty to seventy five
four percent for seventy five two
hundred
five percent four hundred to two fifty
six for two fifty to half a mil
and then seven percent for five hundred
thousand plus so keep this mind so so
far we have the french and indian war we
have the american revolutionary war
we have the french revolutionary war we
have the war of 1812 we have the civil
war
and then that leads to world war 1 1914
to 1918 which u.s got involved
april 2nd 1917. why does this matter
because if you go back and look at the
taxes
in 1916 the top line taxes was 15
the moment we got involved in 1917 taxes
went up to
67 so that was another reason why taxes
went up again
war so then that goes to 1929 to 1933
great depression takes place fdr is the
president
and in 1933 fdr's new deal is being
launched and there's two plans to it
part one of the deal
included the banking act of 1933 and the
securities act of 1933
and part two of it was in 1935 which
introduced social security
minimum wage fair labor standard act and
by 1936 the top tax rate hit 79 percent
and the economy's output plummeted what
we still have uncovered
is world war ii from 1939 to 1945
which the u.s got involved on december 7
1941 so combine the great depression
end world war ii led to in 1945
when fdr died the top marginal tax rate
hit
94 from 1940 to 1963 the top marginal
tax rate
hovered between 81 to 91 percent that's
worth 24
years 81 to 91 by the way just some fun
facts where in 1939 4 million americans
filed taxes
they raised 900 million dollars of tax
revenue by 1943 41 million people
filed taxes for 13 billion of tax
revenue and two years later 43 million
people filed taxes
and the government's revenue went to 45
billion
dollars so remember how in 1862 lincoln
comes out with the irs and says listen
we need to raise money we need to raise
taxes because of civil war was so
expensive
that it led to them coming up with the
tax withholding system which means
the employer is about to pay the
employee thousand dollars that you say
they withhold the taxes and they send to
the government that
and then it went away because lincoln
said when we pay off this debt
this income tax will go away and in 1872
it went away
well let's come to 1943. the war is
still going on world war ii
the party the socialists the liberals
the democrats
went to get help from a guy named milton
friedman
where in 1943 he helped the tax
withholding system become official
where they could start taking taxes out
of your income with
the employer sending the money to the
government essentially the employer
became the tax collector
not the government and here's what
milton friedman had to say about this
later on in life this would have been
introduced had i been involved or not at
the time we concentrated single-mindedly
on promoting the war effort we gave next
to no consideration to any longer-term
consequences
it never occurred to me that at the time
i was helping to develop machinery that
would make possible
a government that i would come to
criticize severely as too large too
intrusive too destructive
of freedom yet that was precisely what i
was doing
quote milton friedman so you may be
saying what's the big deal about this
who care leave them alone you even got
milton friedman and you're painting
why are you making such a big deal about
this here's why
because when lincoln did it he said when
we pay off
all the cost that we paid for the war
civil war
we will stop income taxes however in
when wilson introduced this saying when
we pay off the bill
for world war one when fdr said when we
pay off the bill
for world war ii we will stop taking
income taxes
it never went away it became permanent
and in the tax withholding system
check made it very permanent fyi
you know how old this is 78 years old
that's it the whole tax withholding
thing with your income when you get your
w-2 and again somebody takes all the
taxes out
it's only 78 years old why because no
one said anything about it and it's now
been around for this many years
so here's what's crazy about it this
entire time democrats keep raising taxes
you got wilson you got
you know fdr here taxes raised 94 81
all this stuff being raised and then a
jfk shows up says what are we doing why
do we keep doing this
why do we keep raising taxes it is time
to lower taxes
and he gives this legendary speech in
august of 1962 and here's what he had to
say
a creative tax cut creating more jobs
income and eventually
more revenue and the right time for that
kind of bill now appears
in the absence of an economic crisis
today and if the job is to be done in a
responsible way
is january 1963 such a bill will be
presented to the congress for
action next year it will increase on
across the board top to bottom
cut in both corporate and personal
income taxes it will include long needed
tax reforms
that logic and equity demand and it will
date that cutting taxes to take effect
as of the start of next year january
the billions of dollars this bill will
place in the hands of the consumer and
our businessmen will both have immediate
and permanent benefits to our economy
every dollar released from taxation that
is spent or invested will help create a
new
job and a new salary and these new jobs
and new salaries can create
other jobs and other salaries and more
customers and more growth for an
expanding american economy
a democratic president for tax cuts and
for entrepreneurs
go figure how confusing is this so far
right by the way
when he said january 1st 1963 he gave
the speech on august 13 of 62
he died next year november 22nd the tax
bill went into effect
64 under lyndon johnson and here's what
it looked like he took the top line from
to 70 and he took corporate taxes from
52 to 48
this is in 1964 when this came out 17
years later in 1981 we had the economic
recovery tax of 1981
by ronald reagan which this is what
reagan did reagan
lowered taxes pretty much for everybody
tax rate the top line went from 70 to 50
bottom from 14 to 11 capital gains went
from 28
to 21 higher estate tax exemption went
from 175 thousand
625 to 600 087 he established the ira
the ira for employees and this was
all helped through arthur laffer the
economist and fyi
while reagan came up with us in 1981 and
85 the irs announced that america has
officially produced
400 000 new millionaires due to reagan's
new tax laws
so now i'm going to stop right here
because i don't want this thing to be a
30-minute episode obviously after this
we have bush senior we have clinton we
have bush we have obama we have trump
and we have biden today right but i want
to
kind of show you a couple trends i
noticed here a couple things number one
a lot of times you'll hear about taxes
you know rich don't pay taxes
poor pay too much taxes the rich don't
pay any taxes i wanted to find out who
actually pays the most taxes and what
has happened over the years are the rich
paying less taxes
or the rich paying more taxes and here's
what the data tells us
so there's two charts i want you to look
at the first one is the percentage of
taxpayers this is directly
from the irs okay percentage of
taxpayers let's look at the bottom 50
percent
you can see the majority of the
taxpayers is bottom 50
then the red is the top 25 to 50 percent
then the gray is five to ten the top 105
percent and the black
is the top one percent the richest
people how much how big of a population
there is of the top one percent right
the next one directly from the irs is is
the one percent paying
more or less over the year if you look
at from 1980 to 2018
the top one percent keeps paying more
and more and more taxes
so does the top five percent but the top
10 is about the same from
1980 till today the top 25 is getting
smaller
the top 50 percent is getting smaller
but the bottom
50 percent is definitely getting smaller
and smaller and paying taxes now some of
you may be watching this political year
on the left so wait a minute what are
you saying that
the top shouldn't be paying that much
taxes look the whole purpose of me doing
it this way is to show
how much contradiction there is on the
left and the right
why because everything about the
timeline i showed was what
war war war war war war
war every time we have a war there is
consequences
look how many times we have to raise
taxes
come up with new taxes just to pay off
debt from a war
that we cause or we got involved in this
led me to find out how many military
bases do we have worldwide
and how do we compare to other countries
if i were to ask you right now how many
military bases you think u.s has
outside of the u.s and how many
countries what would you say
you know what the number is 800 foreign
bases
in 70 plus countries do you want to know
how many military bases china has in
foreign countries outside of china
you know how many it is one is in africa
right by the suez canal the choke point
why intentional
it's the only one they have because
they're taking those resources
and they're investing it in the current
modern way
of going to war so now some of the folks
on the right might be saying what are
you saying patrick
are you saying taxes are going up
because we're going to war too many
times
yes america tends to get involved in too
many wars that they don't need to be
getting involved then why because of
control
while instead of keeping that money and
invested into infrastructure maybe in a
different way for military
we're allowing china to get stronger
because they only have one military base
by the way you want to know how many
russia
you want to know how many france you
want to know how many britain have
you know how many total they have
combined 30 they have 30 foreign bases
we have
800 america has eight what do you think
is the cost of that
so you see what's happening when i'm
showing this debt by the way here's the
other part so some of you guys are
saying
that's right republicans are you know
spending way too much money
now if i would ask you a different
question which president do you think
increased the national debt the most
by percentage which one he thinks at the
top ready
so here we go top percentage of national
debt increase during their term first
place
fdr a thousand fifty percent second
woodrow wilson 727
by the way fdr came out with a new deal
woodrow wilson came out
with the 16th amendment third place
ronald reagan 186 percent
fourth george bush 101 barack obama
74 although he has the biggest dollar
amount
of 8.59 trillion dollars increase then
is george h.w bush then it's forward
dennis carter dennis nixon then it's
trump
after taking a deep dive into the topic
of taxes i realized even more
that taxes is not black and white
there's a lot of gray area
whether it's political the influence of
it the cause of it with war
but i was curious the more i learned i
got another 50 pages that i haven't
covered with you if you want me to go
even deeper
with different forms of taxes what other
countries do with taxes press the thumbs
up button and share this episode if this
does well i'll probably do another part
two to this
and if you want today's message napdf
text the word tax
to 310340 one more time text award
tax tax to 310-340-1132 if you're not in
the states go in the description
click on a newsletter subscribe to it
and we'll send you the pdf to you as
well
and last but not least i did another
episode similar to this on the topic of
inflation if you've not watched it click
over here to watch that episode
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye